hey guys it's Joanna here November the
1st is also known as it will be a day a
huge event celebrated by vegans from all
across the world some of you watching
this video might be vegan and some of
you might not be I personally had not a
vegan however I do love to explore the
varieties of vegan recipes which are
healthy easy to make and delicious so
being back in Asia allow me to share one
of my favorite dishes which I discovered
is naturally vegan as well
oriental stir-fried noodles topped with
peanut sauce
this dish is widely eaten across the
Southeast Asia and it can be served
either as a starter or a main course
what I loved about this dish is the
variety of fresh vegetables topped with
my all-time favorite peanut sauce so
let's start by making the peanut sauce
which to me is what makes this dish the
ingredients you need are two tablespoons
of peanut butter 1 tablespoon of soy
sauce 1 garlic clove minced 1 small red
chili deseeded and roughly chopped juice
from one lime 1/2 the tablespoon of
honey or maple syrup one stalk of
lemongrass roughly chopped a small chunk
of ginger costly chopped and three
tablespoons of water place all the
ingredients into a food processor and
process until you get a rubber smooth
and thin paste and set the peanut sauce
aside now let's cook this vibrant and
colorful noodle dish the ingredients
I've use are one bundle of saba of
buckwheat noodles 1 medium carrot 1
large bell pepper thinly sliced 1
zucchini or Japanese cucumber one cup of
bean sprouts half a red onion chopped
into small cubes a
full of charred parsley 20 gram of
peanuts heart half a tablespoon of
sesame oil and 1 small red chili finely
chopped cook the solid rules according
to instruction here's a tip to avoid the
noodles from sticking drain and rinse
with cool water and set it aside spiral
eyes the Japanese cucumber and carrot
into noodles either with a vegetable
spiral slicer or peeler and set insight
key
sesame oil over medium-high heat toss
the peanuts about in the oil until they
are slightly toasted on all sides then
add the onion and chili and saute for
another 2 to 3 minutes until fragrant
finally add the bell pepper bean sprouts
parsley carrots and Japanese cucumber
sort it very quickly for 2 to 3 minutes
and remove from heat to keep the
vegetables crunchy we do not like to
overcook them now it's time to assemble
this beautiful dish in a large bowl take
3/4 of the mixed vegetables and combine
in with the soy noodles then separate
them evenly into two plates
top it up with the remaining mix the
vegetables and finally you can choose to
serve it with the peanut sauce at the
side or drizzle the sauce onto the dish
if you want to pack this out then choose
to pair the peanut sauce separately to
keep the veggies fresh and crunchy these
virtual noodles topped with peanut sauce
is to die for
each serving is just under 400 F
calories with a huge serving of
vegetables and complex carbs from the
soba noodles this new would keep you
satisfied for a very long time and
you're getting two to three servings of
vegetables and healthy fed from the
peanut sauce so this simple dish makes a
very healthy meal you can also choose to
serve it with other solar noodles and
serve it as a starter or replace the
Solano's with another complex carbs of
your choice
vegan or not try this recipe out and
share your creation with me on Facebook
and Instagram are the best for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you
you